you sort of performing very very young
how do young are we talking here three
you what are you doing it three radio
commercials doing way to you it yeah
well there's a cold pressure front
coming in what yeah I was doing for K
Mart Kmart they when they started doing
their photobooth thing or photo
developing it used to be this thing or
we had film and these things called
cameras and then you take it and you
would get it developed everyone in the
audience is texting right that's what
I'm saying and I played Miz goof-proof
to a fellow named Josh Richmond's mr.
goof proof-- know and so he did these
commercials for four years and they got
like Clio words and stuff and I the only
line I ever remember from doing that was
Jeffrey are you the opposite sex or am i
and I always thought that was like it
was the 7d yeah it's all wrong and said
yeah that was just seems weird and in a
short commercial but went from that to
photo development right
tired of gender confusion yeah use Kodak
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]